Everyone is familiar with gum.
Well, we've got our hands
on a whole bunch of gumballs,
and we're going
to see what happens
if you put them into a blender
in a few different ways.
[Music]
We've got a nice
powerful blender here,
and we also have
a whole lot of gumballs.
This isn't even all of them.
We've got more gumballs
in this bag,
and this bag comes
with almost 700.
We got to try some stuff.
All right, these appear
to be little ball of gum.
Thin candy coating on the
outside to give us some color,
and probably some flavor,
a dummy bit,
little bit of air in the middle.
So I just want to point out,
one of these tiny little
gumballs is 10 calories a piece.
The first three ingredients
are different types of sugar.
Sugar, sugar, sugar,
and then a gum base,
and the gum base,
it's literally rubber.
Like rubber from a rubber tree,
very similar to rubber bands.
Let's start out with a few
smaller scale test though.
Let's try putting in
like 10 gumballs in,
and seeing what happens
if we blend them up.
Maximum power.
Oh no--
[Music]
Um, I was not expecting
that to work.
Wow.
I thought that
the inside gum part would
have liked more resistance,
and it wouldn't get broken up.
But like this is,
we just made gum powder.
Like that's a really
fine powder even.
So we got a white powder.
There are these chunks.
>> Oh, no, it's just...
>> No, Just...
>> Wow.
>> Come together a little bit.
White powder was specs
of color all through it.
Well, I got to try some of this.
Oh, yeah.
[Music]
I can feel a lot of it
just to dissolve away.
The sugar is gone immediately.
Oh, it was a very
big handful I got.
I think I maybe,
I'm swallowing something.
There's not a lot of gum left.
Yeah that really
powderized quite a bit.
Let's do five hundred gumballs,
unchewed in the blender.
Let's do it.
[Music]
That's 250.
500.
[Music]
Oh my god.
It's actually collapsing
over on this side.
I think--
Yeah, the blades are
probably like holding
it open a little bit,
and so now, yeah,
this side--
I did not expect
that to work that well.
Wow.
What's that like?
Like kinetic sand?
Mmm.
Oh my goodness.
This is fun.
It's like edible kinetic sand.
It doesn't like hold
itself together as much.
No, it feels similar though.
It does.
It does feel very similar
to kinetic sand honestly.
Just the slight cohesion.
Here, Nate.
I made this for you.
Oh good.
[Music]
All right, 500 gumballs
reduced to powder.
The more you play with it,
the less like
kinetic sand it is.
It's just becoming a mess.
I'm gonna add
a little bit of water.
See if we can make
this look like chewed gum.
All right.
Well, there's some
wet gumball sand.
It's picking up a lot of the dye
and the shells of the gumballs.
All right.
I'm going to try
some of this too.
That looks even less appealing.
Mmm.
Yeah, that was
like a wet gumball.
Does it-- Does it taste
like you just pick up
somebody's chewed gum,
and put it in your mouth?
Actually, there's a lot
more flavor than normal.
Because the water--
I'm like choking on it.
The water like rinsed
off a lot of the sugar
and the dye and the flavor,
and I'm just getting
that all immediately at once,
instead of it being released
as I chew it.
[Music]
Yeah, that's a--
Potent.
Yeah, that tastes
like 17 gumballs all
at the same time.
That was pretty cool.
We got some gumball sand.
Now, we want to try and put
it in with some water,
see what happens.
There it goes.
[Music]
More gumball?
More gumball.
I think we need to add more.
[Music]
Yeah, we got a big
old lump in there.
It was getting really
mad about that--
Blender chewed gum.
Oh, that just very
strong gumball smell
comes flooding out.
Smells better than
before you blend them though.
Less chemical, more
actually like a--
Oh no.
It's wet chewed gum.
But it did.
It's really like the consistency
of chewed gum.
I don't know.
Okay. Well, we have to try this too.
All right, just remind myself.
No one has chewed this gum.
I hate this.
This is not technically
pre-chewed gum.
Oh no!
[Music]
Now, I'm struggling.
Oh, it's really really soft.
Rubbery.
The water that we used
was a little bit warm,
and then the blender
actually can heat stuff up
if you blend it enough.
I think it did that.
This is like you just
put somebody's previously
chewed gum right in here mouth.
Except it has all
of the flavor first.
Yeah, for like
the first 10 seconds,
then there's no more flavor.
It goes away immediately.
So that was like making
like a concentrated gumball.
It was--
It was sickly sweet kind
of thing like, so much.
I don't know how you fit
that much sweetness into
that little liquid to the point
that I wasn't actually
able to swallow it
because it was gonna
make me nausea.
But that's a lot
of chewed gum right there,
blender chewed and then
person chewed afterward.
But the blender did.
It did.
The blender chewed the gum.
I just have to remember
that every choice
I've made in my life up
until this point has led
me to this moment.
[Music]
Is it sweet?
>> No.
>> Does it taste like bubble gum?
Yeah, you know
how concentrated that was?
This is worse.
Oh wow.
This is so sweet, it's like--
Normally, like sugar is good.
I love sugar.
But this hits a level that like,
like your body almost
wants to reject it,
but it still taste good.
That's the weird part.
Give it a try.
[Music]
Oh my gosh.
Well, we've got another
experiment we need to do,
and a lot more gumballs.
Now, we want to actually
try and put pre-chewed gum
into the blender.
This is going to take a while.
It is gonna take a while.
I think for speed sake,
we'll probably try two doing
to gum balls at once,
but it's still going
to take a while.
Should we livestream this?
No.
Two hours later.
So we're not a 500 yet.
But our stomachs really hurt.
This is so much sugar...
Stomach hurts, jaw
hurts a little bit.
So we have an idea of what might
make this a little bit easier,
and it's gonna change
the gum balls a little bit,
but I think it's worth it.
So the idea is
that we're going to actually
get rid of this candy
coated shell on the outside.
That's where a lot of the sugar
and flavoring is.
We're hoping that
if we can rinse these
off in hot water,
and remove that so it's
just the gum itself,
it might go a little
bit easier on us.
So unfortunately,
in the inside,
it is white,
so I think our gumball stopped
being so colorful.
But it's going to be easier
on us to get
through 500 gumballs.
[Music]
Well, we did that.
We chewed so much gum.
So you can see,
we've got the colored gum
from we left the shells on,
and the rest of the gum from
after we washed it off.
And it did make it
a little bit easier,
but oh my goodness,
that was so much gum.
Well, most of these
are two pieces of gum,
and then Calli
also made a couple
where there are some tens
and there's a 25 gumball blob.
Okay.
Let's throw these
in the blender,
and turn it on.
[Music]
It's more than I
thought it would be.
[Music]
Oh, no.
Error.
Overload.
Just hit the highest setting.
I'll try and see.
Do it.
[Music]
Oh, no, it's binding.
Overload.
You can actually smell
the motor overheating.
[Music]
A little bit of hot water,
see how it goes.
We'll see if that helps at all.
Still can't handle it.
Kinda like loosen
it up a little bit.
[Music]
So the blob was just
like sitting on the top
of the blades,
and it was like being spun
around, not falling in.
And I'm actually afraid
of what would happen
if it hit the blades
all at once.
I think this is now
a chewed gum smoothie.
Oh.
Would you like some?
Mark?
[Music]
Blendered gum.
There you go.
That's about 500 gumballs
and a little bit of water.
Oh no, why would you do this?
Viewers have got to know.
They have a right to see this.
I don't think anybody deserves
to have to see this.
I'm sorry then, viewers.
A comparison.
It is basically the same
number of gumballs.
It is.
Guys, that was fun.
But we've always got more
for you to see.
This box up here at the top will
take you to our latest video.
That box down
to the bottom will show you
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next.
And if you're not subscribed,
hit this bomb in the middle.
That will make you a subscriber,
and that way,
you'll never miss out a video.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we will see you
in the next one.
Talk to you then.